demain ce sera le grand prix d'autriche
et peut-être le jour de gloire de niki
lauda devant son public largement en
tête au classement du championnat du
monde
lauda n'a que 26 ans et une pilote en
formule 1 que depuis quatre ans ses
débuts avaient été difficiles il du même
consentir à hypothéquer sa propre vie
pour emprunter l'argent nécessaire à un
banquier qui ne consentit à la lui
prêter qu'à condition qu'ils souscrivent
en sa faveur une assurance d'un montant
équivalent c'est ce qui s'appelle
risquer sa peau en 1974 il fut engagé
par feral neuf fois meilleur temps aux
essais vainqueur de deux grands prix
quatrième au championnat
il fut la révélation de l'année cette
saison il a déjà mis six pole position
et quatre victoires à son actif et avec
17 points d'avance il a presque le titre
en poche
mais malgré tout le bruit fait autour de
lui lauda est encore un homme secret
c'est que travailleur acharné toujours
très concentré il n'aime guère perdre de
temps à se confier à la veille du grand
prix d'allemagne alors qu'il venait
d'entrer dans la légende en brisant le
premier la barrière 17 minutes sur le
nürbürgring il a pourtant consenti à
répondre aux questions d'automoto l'an
dernier au même moment il était le
favori de cette course et du championnat
mais il sorti de la route dès le premier
tour perdit le grand prix et le titre
referait-il de la même erreur un an plus
tard
on ne peut pas car c'est vrai que l'an
dernier poussé par les circonstances
j'ai commis une erreur c'est vrai aussi
que cette année je ne crois pas que je
le répèterai pour deux réseaux les
données du problème ne sont plus les
mêmes
et puis moi aussi j'ai changé il avait
mûri naturellement et j'espère bien
continuer c'est ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant progresser s'améliorait
toujours la vente déjà reproché de
prendre trop de risques
cette année on vous a trouvé trop
prudent qu'en pensez vous c'est idiot
les risques on les calcule en fonction
de chaque situation
en 74 je n'avais pas beaucoup d' avance
il fallait absolument que je gagne cette
saison au contraire la situation exige
que je prenne aussi le risque possible
et pas besoin d'accroître mon avance je
cherche la concerne
c'est un gros avantage de conduire une
ferrari ici s'il a dit sur certains
circuits c'est la ferrari qui tient
mieux la route sur d'autres c'est
contraire au total je ne crois pas être
vraiment avantagés
quelle part jouent la chance dans des
résultats d'un pilote je ne crois pas à
la chance - pas totalement neuf fois sur
dix on accuse la malchance a tort au
lieu d'analyser problème est de trouver
des raisons qui l'ont provoquée à
combien évaluez vous vos chances de
remporter le titre cette année
je n'y croirai que quand j'en aurai la
certitude mathématique
quel est votre plus dangereux rival
fittipaldi sûrement
pourquoi c'est le plus vite ça ne veut
rien dire le plus vite ce qu'il faut
c'est savoir aller vite quand c'est
nécessaire c'est une question de
jugement
ces types aldi et très forts pour ça
quel est votre idéal dans la vie faire
ce que j'aime avancer progresser pour le
moment c'est ce que m'apporte la cour
suprême mais le jour où j'aurai atteint
mon plafond comme pilote
j'arrêterai aussitôt de courir qu'est ce
que vous détestez le plus dans la vie
les intrigues héros il n'y a pas au
monde deux êtres semblables alors
inutile de vouloir imiter quelqu'un on
peut prendre des exemples ici et là ça
dépend en particulier mais il vaut mieux
se consacrer à développer sa propre
personnalité
une femme en formule 1 ça nous choque
après tout la femme comme l'homme est un
être humain c'est vrai qu'il y ait une
différence mais ça n'a rien à voir être
le pilotage avait beaucoup d'amis
beaucoup quand je gagne très peu quand
justement de le rester quand j'ai perdu
si vous n'étiez pas pilote de course que
feriez vous j'aime beaucoup volé
actuellement c'est ce qui m'intéresse le
plus j'aimerais d'avion professionnels
quelle est la caractéristique principale
de votre personnalité
eh bien je pense que c'est d'être aussi
précis aussi lucide que possible et
donner force et de donner le maximum de
moi même
l'argent pour vous ça compte beaucoup
bien sûr l'argent c'est nécessaire pour
vivre pour manger pour dormir et devenir
un homme à six non ça ne m'intéresse pas
avez vous une devise non le monde est en
constante évolution
je m'efforce d'évoluer avec lui vous
êtes le directeur sportif de la scuderia
ferrari depuis deux ans vous êtes entré
en fonctions en même temps que niki
lauda est ce vous qui l'avez choisi
procès
j'avais parlé avec monsieur ferraille
parce que je veux vini qui à monte carlo
à mon accord avec la bière et enfin le
très bon course intelligente je pense
que c'est très facile de travailler avec
nicky parce que ça à personne très
correct tracy cesse inchirah ça pour moi
c'est très important comme copilote je
pense que nicky l'économie très bien la
voiture
il est très sensible pour la voiture et
le bien pour faire l'essai pour les
points
[Applaudissements]
son ami vous êtes mieux placé que
quiconque pour nous dire quel est sont
sont des faux cils en à un oui oui c'est
moi encore tous l'appellent songez par
johnny qui oscille à beaucoup des
différents je pense qu'il est très froid
de pensée qui sera champion du monde
cette année et coûte
j'espère beaucoup le lendemain lauda
prenait la tête du grand prix
d'allemagne
il ne devait pas le gagner mais cette
fois ce ne devait pas être de sa faute
seul un magnifique patrick de paille et
parvenait à garder le contact avec lui
comme soudée l'une à l'autre d'un fait
rare ils attirent elles se livraient un
somptueux duel
et puis presque en même temps les deux
héros malheureux de cette course
échevelée allait être a frappé la
suspension de paille et cassait tandis
que comme beaucoup l'aude a crevé le
temps de faire changer sa roue la
victoire s'étaient envolés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
importe la troisième place que niki
lauda réussit à sauvegarder ce jour là
valait tout de même de l'or elle leur
approche est encore un peu du titre
mondial
[Musique]